the other thing of course is that make
you Tom Brady fan from New England I
couldn't believe you guys partnered up
with him I've drawn ground um what can
you tease people about the specifics of
the project have you guys said anything
well Brady is a historic athlete who has
accomplished things that no one else has
accomplished especially the game of
football
and what we're so fascinated by is the
mindset behind that and how he prepares
himself mentally how he keeps his body
in peak physical condition how it keeps
his mind in peak physical condition the
way he preps mentally for every game
that's what we're fascinated by and and
so the project really is you know him
examining the game of football from the
high school level to the college level
to the pro level you're getting insights
from him about the best way to prepare
and the best way to play the game and so
it's really a peek inside the brain of
you know perhaps the you know greatest
the greatest minds peek inside the
greatest mind in the play football so
this is a theatrical project this is a
be an IMAX theatrical release something
that you know could live on IMAX screens
for years around the country and around
the world so you're planning on filming
when he's at Tampa Bay that's part of
the movie that's correct